un nuevo caso de brutalidad policial
contra una estadounidense despertó la
indignación en eeuu clive owens by de 39
años fue sacado por la fuerza de su
automóvil por la policía de dayton ohio
no puedo salir con tiene que salir del
coche no puedo salir soy parapléjico te
has metido en el coche puede salir del
coche
pese a que aún es by repitió varias
veces su imposibilidad de salir del
automóvil a no poder usar sus piernas
los uniformados lo arrastran
violentamente del vehículo en el que se
encontraba también su hijo de tres años
y lo inmovilizan en el suelo mientras
jóvenes by pide ayuda
el incidente se produjo el pasado 30 de
septiembre pero el departamento policial
de dayton reveló este fin de semana el
vídeo con los hechos señalando que se
está investigando lo ocurrido los
agentes justificaron la detención
diciendo que el hombre se alejaba de una
casa en la que se traficaba con drogas
sin embargo no ha sido acusada en ningún
delito relacionado con narcotráfico o
west bay dijo en una entrevista con el
canal sí en el que temió por su vida y
su abogado presentar una demanda contra
los agentes ya que considera lo sucedido
como ilegal e innecesariamente brutal la
actuación de los oficiales
recuerdo la muerte del afro
estadounidense 'george floyd luego de
ser brutalmente agredido por un agente
de tránsito blanco hace más de un año su
asesinato desencadenó una ola de
protestas mundiales bajo el movimiento
blacks light matter que sigue justicia
para este tipo de actos racistas y el
respeto a los derechos de la comunidad
afro en eeuu